so what are the best ways to earn one
thousand dollars on YouTube and Beyond
in 2023 in this video we're gonna be
learning from two creators who like
everybody started from scratch and have
grown to 50 000 subscribers and over 150
000 they're going to be sharing really
practical advice that really nobody is
telling you and they're going to be
talking about the good and the bad and
even the challenging aspects of how cool
it is to be earning money in the crater
economy but also some of the Practical
behind the scenes details that are going
to be really helpful so I want to
encourage you to buckle your seatbelt
for this deep dive training and uh we're
going to be getting into seven different
ways to earn money on YouTube this year
and if you're watching this on our think
media podcast Channel smash the like
button and I want to welcome
wavy curly Courtney to the stream
Courtney how's it going
I'm doing amazing and thank you so much
for jumping on to share wisdom today
tell us a little bit about when you
started your channel and uh about what
you're doing on YouTube
absolutely thank you so much for having
me I'm honored to be here
um the YouTube channel grew out of my
Instagram page back in the day in 2019
there were no long-form content
options available on Instagram and I had
started playing around with this thing
called the curly girl method and playing
around with my hair and different things
that worked and didn't work and people
had questions they wanted to see the
process and YouTube was the next logical
step in demonstrating how to care for
wavy curly hair and I started having a
lot of fun with it uploading and doing
my best to encourage people to embrace
the hair that they are fearfully and
wonderfully made with
man I love the vision and uh how long
have you been on YouTube now
I believe my first curly hair upload was
in January of 2019. but it was really
interesting yeah amazing and 144 000
subscribers and four uploads in the last
month that we'll be talking about some
of just the Tactical and practical
things
um and so we'll get into the tips in
just a second but I also want to welcome
Denise Jordan the apron Diva how's it
going Denise it's going great thank you
Sean for having me I'm so glad to be
here
uh so always love having you on the show
and uh breakdown for us a little bit
about what your channel is what your
vision is and how long you've been on
YouTube
I've been on YouTube about five years
but I started out doing makeup because I
just wanted to have fun with that and
then I wanted to do something a little
bit more so I got into home making and I
kind of fell into it because I did a
little of this and a little of that but
what I found out resonated with my
viewers was homemaking they wanted to
learn how to cook how to clean how to do
laundry how to do those things we need
to make and keep a home
so that's how that ended up and um
I think the fact that I've got a lot of
history in homemaking they felt that I
had the wisdom to actually share some
practical tips yeah that's amazing and
both uh of your channels are growing you
grew 300 subscribers just in the last
month a thousand for Courtney just the
last month and you guys are uh doing
incredible things and I'm excited to
dive into these tips today but we're
going to kick it off with these seven
different ways to make money and of
course we're going to start the
conversation with YouTube ads you know
everybody wants to get monetized in the
YouTube Partner program
um that's not you don't actually have to
be monetized to start making money
whether it's affiliate marketing or some
of the other things we're going to talk
about but we'll start with you Courtney
when did you first get monetized do you
remember that and how long it took and
uh what maybe percentage of that is it
of your overall income that comes in
from YouTube
I do I remember the day I got monetized
I was actually uh had just completed my
first half marathon and was with my
family and saw that the channel had
finally finally gotten to the 4 000
hours that I needed to get monetized it
was June of 2019 and I would say now the
percentage of my income that comes from
YouTube ads is roughly
20 it's really not the biggest source of
my
income at this point yeah that's a and
that's a pretty common experience uh for
people that YouTube ads are cool once
you get there but there's a lot of other
ways to earn money so uh I love that
story how about for you Denise do you
remember when you first got monetized I
got monetized probably about a year into
my channel for this and that was Denise
Jordan and probably YouTube ads are
about 20 to 25
of my uh income as well and it just
depends upon what season it is as well
because between September and um
December my YouTube money goes way up
and then at other times of the year it
kind of trickles down just a little bit
so it is definitely seasonal yeah you
Just Dropped a Bomb there and that's one
cool thing about YouTube ads is
different niches have different cpms and
different times of the year advertisers
are spending more money around the
holidays they want to get in front of
your audience different times of the
year so it's kind of cool to see that it
it can go up and
um and you there's a lot of different
opportunity there well let's jump into
number two which is Amazon Affiliates
specifically and uh Courtney we'll kick
it back to you
um tell us a little bit about your
experience with affiliate marketing and
uh break it down
I had some great success with Amazon in
2020 I have not kept up with the
platform as it updates so my Amazon
storefront is not a great example guys
I'm so sorry uh but now that you have
the ability to upload video content and
Link the products that are in the videos
uh which is pretty cool but I'm not
doing that to its fullest extent I do
love Amazon Affiliates because I can
take every product that I mentioned in a
video and create a link that produces
income for me so if someone watches one
of my videos they can find the exact
product I used in that video and I make
a small Commission because of the Amazon
affiliates yeah there's a couple things
I want to dig in there I mean uh it does
speak to this is a lot of work it's work
to stay up on it you've got two kids you
know you're juggling different things in
life and so uh I see a couple things
that we could dig in on here you're uh
we'll come back to this since these are
not Amazon links and we'll talk about
other affiliate links later but we do
have your Amazon shop
that I'm sure when did you apply for
this how long were how how big was your
Channel
I actually got approved for this back uh
when before the YouTube channel had
become monetized I applied for it uh
with my Instagram account I believe I
had 5 000 followers on on Instagram and
uh I don't know what I think that was
the Threshold at the time that you had
to have in order to be eligible to apply
got it so one of the things that's a
real distinction here is you can set up
an Amazon shop and there's a vertical
video uploaded here the product you're
using is down below it and this gives
you the ability to make ideas lists and
do videos and you're exactly right
there's there's a whole other
opportunity of going live on Amazon
uploading videos sharing this link out
and really scaling up your Amazon
affiliate revenue of course you can also
then link inside of the videos
themselves if there's a specific Amazon
product
um and that's fascinating to consider
too that building your influence on
different platforms could be helpful I
know back when I first even applied for
Amazon I just submitted a Blog you can
use just your YouTube channel but if you
have influence other places sometimes
that could be the key and then how about
for you Denise um you also when did you
get your shop approved do you remember I
got my Amazon affiliate approved
probably within the first year after I
started my channel I was doing VRA and
it said sign up for an Amazon affiliate
so I went ahead and did that
um but my Amazon influencer store came
about a year or so after that but one of
the things that I want to point out is
that Amazon does as well as you do for
it for example I'm not the best at every
time I'm putting up a video promoting
the different products that I have in
the video I will do it and I'll I keep a
list of the different links and things
like that of the products that I'm using
and I'll put those in the description
box I'll invite people to check out my
Amazon store but there's an art and a
science to promoting Amazon products if
you wanted to do that so in addition to
the ones that come with your video but
like Valentine's Day is coming up you
could promote some things specifically
for that Christmas is coming then you
can promote some holiday items so you
can really do quite well on Amazon if
you work for it yeah that's a great
point and
um this is one of my favorite videos
that you did my prepper Pantry grocery
haul we talked about this earlier
because I think also this came up when
people were came out when people were
locked down yes and yeah so they're kind
of in that mentality and we were talking
about the strategy of trend surfing so
not just a smart time to put that out
there but then in the description here
you've got stuff like whole powdered
eggs I'm going over to Amazon and this
is your affiliate link and again another
cool thing is that sometimes you know
getting some dried porcini mushrooms is
only a 14 purchase but when someone
clicks your link you can get credit for
things that you didn't even link to have
you ever looked in inside of your Amazon
and saw oh well I got credit for
something weird that I never talked
about have you ever studied that I
haven't really studied that but I've
heard you talk about how someone bought
some coins or something like that from
um one of your links when they came to
yours yeah it sounds like Courtney saw
something Courtney what'd you see I
somebody bought a very expensive Grill
through one of mine and I got
commissioned for that yes yeah it's
amazing the more videos you have out
there and I like what you said Denise is
like it really is an art form that's one
of the things that we try to break down
in VRA is in order to make certain
videos especially the review specific
products type videos kind of what you
say when you say it making it sure that
you know you're linking to these
products and whatnot clearly and making
you know helping get those clicks is all
part of it but we've covered YouTube ads
and Amazon Affiliates the third one is
merch and we are going to uh start with
Denise here because you're you're crutch
crushing merch and you've learned a lot
you're kind of taking it to a different
level you've built out a brand talk
about this experience with what you've
been doing here well I always wear
aprons in my cooking cleaning crafting
videos and people would always ask where
do you get your aprons so I decided that
I would just sell aprons and that would
be my merch and I just wanted to have
merch like so many of the other
YouTubers had but what I didn't realize
at the time was they're not holding
inventory and I am so everything you see
up on the screen I've got like in the
back bedroom so I have to promote it
somewhat differently I have to actively
promote the brand and that's something
that I do
and um
it takes a lot of discipline and you
have to pay a lot more attention when
you're actually holding inventory
because if you don't it's going to be
sitting in your room and it's not going
to be selling
so my business model is that when I do a
video I'll wear an apron depending upon
what holiday it is I might have on a
holiday apron and then I'll just put the
name of the apron in the video and then
I just do my thing but that stimulates
people to purchase
that's uh that's amazing and so
practically how challenging was it to
learn to kind of set up the website and
build out get the merch sourced and
whatnot I mean if we're one of the goals
of this video is to kind of just give
the realistic Vision I mean what we know
is that inside of the crater economy we
can make good money we can make a
difference yes um we can work from home
we can do all this kind of stuff but
also it also takes work and it takes
strategy and it takes skill building and
so
um yeah what was kind of at least some
of your process of picking your website
building your website building your
logos out all that kind of stuff well I
had a couple of people that were
supporting me to help to build the logo
and build the website and those kind of
things so I didn't have to do that I had
a team that helped me with that the
hardest part for me though was figuring
out where to Source the product where
was I going to Source the aprons which
aprons where I you know am I going to
make aprons and and then how many am I
going to make how many am I going to
source
when are they going to be coming in what
kind to buy what's going to be popular
all those kinds of things and then the
other part was just learning about
business when I started this business I
didn't know revenue from profit margin I
didn't know there was a difference and I
know now but at the time these were
things that I had to learn was what
revenue is and how do you plan ahead and
and plan ahead for various Seasons so
there's a lot of learning curve that I
had to go through but it worked out very
well I kind of had them in telling that
if I build it they will come and they
will somewhat come the first year but
the second year you got to do more
and when you say team was this somebody
you hired was this friends you enlisted
like who was the team that was helping
you well my sister is my administrative
assistant so she's the one that built
the website and that kind of thing and
then the person that helped me uh
developed my logo and do some of the
branding was a friend of my daughters
and she did some graphic design so she
helped me with that and then if when I
really got into pint and I had a
question I would call my son who was
working in um advertising at the
particular time so my sister's my
daughter's friend helped develop the
logo for that and then created the
banner and all of that my sister puts
everything up on the website because I
don't know how to do that so she puts
all the pictures up she manages the site
but I'm the one that talks with the
supplier I'm the one that orders things
in I'm the one that has to you know take
the pictures of the aprons or get
somebody to model the apron so I would
get my niece and her girls to uh model
the acres for the mommy and me my niece
and her daughters when it was Father's
Day I'd get a couple of my sons well I
have two sons so I would get them to do
it and man I love that and what you're
really sharing here is that there's the
need of of leadership skills of casting
vision of enrolling people around you I
love the family Dynamic you know you got
friends family sister son like different
things happening and not everyone has
the same situation but you're a real
entrepreneur in the fact of it's not
about your resources it's about your
resourcefulness you know if you're a
part of our Challenge and if you're
watching this on the think media podcast
there's still time to join you can go to
tube challenge we're on the final
sessions but we have it tomorrow we have
limited replays
tube1kchallenge.com but
um you know one of the things that we
think about is what are the resources
that we have in our life who who could
we enlist what are some of the systems
what are some of the people that we
could get in our world so that they
especially could rally around this
monetization piece build a website
administrative assistant or just help
watch the kids to free you up to create
content man who can you get on your team
but I want to talk to Courtney off
camera we were talking a little bit
about you've dabbled in merch I would
say we've done the same at think media
um we use just Teespring it's connected
to the website I want to say we've
connect we've promoted it literally zero
times like I think we set it up because
we wanted to order like our own hat and
just like put in the order and uh and
and you kind of had a similar experience
like in a way that maybe merch isn't for
everybody what was your experience
I went through printful it was just one
more task for me to have to stay on top
of and I have very limited resources in
my time that is one thing that I need to
work on is building the team around me
but merch just wasn't producing the
income that it needed to in order to
make it worth the time that was required
so it was fun but not necessary yeah and
I like that it's the power of focus I
also think that you know it's also
passion and vision I mean Denise You've
Got a Brand apron Diva it feels like it
just it works and and there's a passion
behind it so we're we're making these
decisions at the intersection of maybe
it is our resources who can we enlist on
our team who do we have around us it
also is our passion what is it we love
doing how do we want to show up in the
world and serve the world
um but when it comes to these seven
different ways of monetizing it's not
that we have to do all of them it's that
we can pick a combination that works
best for our brand our passion and and
uh kind of Choose Your Own Adventure
which brings us to number four which we
split out here and that is other
affiliate programs and wherever you're
watching this stream smash like if
you're already getting value but besides
Amazon and I wouldn't even really
consider Amazon Central although it is
um a really popular one because they
sell everything by getting clicks on
your links you can earn credit for a lot
of other things but besides Amazon there
is other affiliate programs and so
Denise what are some of the
um different affiliate programs you've
been a part of for your Channel
one of the ones which I am probably most
proud of is my affiliate with Caraway
home cookware it's a brand of cookware
it's a lovely cookware and I enjoy using
it and I do a lot of videos using the
cookware and then when someone purchased
the purchases the cookware I get a
percentage of that purchase that's one
of the ones that I've been involved with
and then of course
um there's other ones like true Earth
and there's my unboxing when I did that
one
but yeah but you know you can get a a
kickback from doing that
um true Earth is another one that I
worked with as not only an affiliate but
also as a sponsor and then you get a
link that they give you and then when
people purchase
um you get a percentage from that new
air is another one that I've worked with
that has proved to be very good for me
amazing and this is sometimes you're
called Ambassador programs partner
programs affiliate programs and so this
is the uh Denise's link to the care way
and Courtney you even earlier I was
clicking around and I clicked on one of
your videos that that brought me over to
Sally beauty.com and so what are some of
the other affiliate programs that you've
um
I gotta press and hold to prove I'm not
a bot here we go uh that you've been a
part of
uh this particular link was magic links
um I personally try and make sure that
if I'm going to link an affiliate link
it's to a product that has the best
price so sometimes I can't necessarily
link to Amazon Affiliates uh magic links
allows you to link to a broader range of
sites and give you a percentage of the
commission I've worked with a lot of
hair care Brands over the years as I am
quite niched down I am available for a
lot of affiliate programs so there's
quite a few products quite a few
companies that I work with that I enjoy
that I get a percentage commission for
sending traffic to their site
I gotcha and and so I like that uh
breakdown magic links what is magic
links when did you sign up for that and
yeah what is it
it's similar to like to know it uh that
all the really cool influencers use but
magic links gives you a very small
commission and I use it to link to
Walmart and Sally Beauty and
Target Target a lot yeah that's a good
tip too because sometimes it's hard to
get approved for those ones it's hard to
get approved for Walmart or Target
directly but magic links is in the
middle and it's easier typically to get
approved there and one of the things I
love that you did is you kind of have
this is on your website you have a
things you recommend page it leads to
your Amazon shop which is cool and
eventually once you know you apply to
the Amazon influencer program you can
get your own affiliate kind of shop and
page on Amazon but on here then you've
got inner sense and curl Smith and
Carrollton and mop top so these are this
is you're doing a lot of different
affiliate marketing here you got promo
codes and the code here
um where are you hosting your website
content
so this is in conjunction with my online
course when I built out my website I
also built out an online course uh and I
house everything through cartridge
awesome and so um that was our number
fourth tip other affiliate programs and
as you can see friends the affiliate
Rabbit Hole goes super deep and it
really is endless no matter what your
Niche is
um you know it could be survival where
you know gear fishing all types of
clothing brands uh software Affiliates
is a pretty massive opportunity and it's
about finding the right affiliate
programs for you and we're going to get
into the rest of these tips but I want
to remind you that
um one there's still time to get into
the challenge if you're watching this
publicly and I want to encourage you
this weekend we're leaving the replays
up of seven sessions and we're calling
it our learn and level up weekend if
you're in the challenge group make sure
that you catch up on all the sessions
get all of the notes because we want you
to crush it this year get your first or
next thousand subscribers get your first
or next a thousand dollars and
um addition to that we we do have a
giveaway coming up in the challenge
group a little bit later and Mel on the
think team will be back on and so after
the main content definitely meet us in
the group or if you're not signed up get
signed up because it's all going down
there and then another reminder is uh
there is limited time left to get that
extra bonus on our learn video 2023.com
limited time offer that's our video
raking Academy program and I'll tell you
a little bit more about what's happening
there if you haven't heard about that
let yet but just a heads up especially
if you want everything laid out if you
love the idea of having all the steps
and all the right order in terms of
YouTube and monetizing your channel
that's the point of that so definitely
head over to learnvideo2023.com to see
all the details of that special and
limited offer but next up is brand
sponsorships and you both touched on
this uh but this is an aspiration that
we all have I think because brand
sponsorships could be very lucrative we
all see people that say this video is
brought to you by or there's hashtag ad
so Denise what's kind of been your
experience with working with brand
sponsorships and you know when did they
first reach out what did you reach out
was there an email to you I know that
sometimes people get emails they're kind
of nervous because sometimes it feels
like maybe someone's taking advantage of
you or is it a trick what are some of
the things you've learned
one of the things that I've learned is a
lot of times when we're talking about
brand sponsorships or brand Partnerships
a lot of the brands want to just gift
you with items they want to send you
free product and then have you do your
video about their product and that's a
good way to start to kind of cut your
teeth and to just practice but they also
want access to your audience to your
viewers so after you practice long
enough then it's time for them to start
paying you some money for
doing all of that work so I now don't
take free products at all it's like if
you want me to promote your product then
you need to pay me for that and the
price can go anywhere from two hundred
dollars to a thousand dollars depending
upon what it is that they want you to
promote how long they want that um say
if they want you to run a video clip or
something like that if they want a
dedicated video
and it can be very lucrative and I get a
lot of people reaching out now but I say
no to a lot of them
and why do you say no to a lot of them
do sponsorships I don't do brands for
for any kind of product it's not
directly related to the people that
watch me because they don't want to see
some nft thing
um or I'm
this and that with Denise Jordan what
they're interested in is cooking
cleaning laundry things that you need to
do to keep and make a home so those are
the only Partnerships that I will accept
for example one of the ones that I work
with is new air so new they've sent me a
freezer for me to promote is something
that's definitely related to my viewers
so it's something that I will promote I
like it I use it a lot I think it's
something my viewers can use
particularly my Preppers so it's
something that I'll consider doing but
if it's not relevant I just don't even
bother with it because it's a lot of
work to do a sponsorship video because
there's a lot of eyes to Dot and tees to
cross when you're doing that because
they have expectations as well and you
need to meet those and it's not fun
reshooting the video
yeah no doubt about it and so I love
that you're sharing just the real behind
the scenes that's it is true when you
take on a brand it's kind of like having
a boss like you gotta yeah once you kind
of get in a contractual agreement there
may be some edits there may be some
revisions so it's a blessing but it
comes with some responsibility but you
dropped an incredible nugget in that
last bit there and that was really the
reason you're saying no is because
you're putting your audience first
exactly and I think that people
100 that the point of these ways of
making money is that uh making money is
not bad some people have money mindsets
it's like like oh I don't want to make
money or we could be uncomfortable
selling and those types of things that's
completely reasonable oh if I'm
promoting a brand well it's not really
if you do it it's how you do it and it's
also the order of how you do things
money isn't the first thing we know that
money is something that we get based on
the amount of value we give to the
marketplace and if you've built a trust
and you've built up your audience then
the other key is we don't want to make
short-term money oh you can kind of be
like oh that brand didn't really fit and
maybe you got some short-term money but
you lost some trust with your audience
right the key would be the balance of of
both and I love that your vision is to
be selective there I'm curious from
Courtney similarly uh what kind of brand
deal experience have you had in brand
sponsorships
one of the best Partnerships I had was
one where they I reached out to them I
was like hey I love your products I want
to work with you can we work together
and they told me no but because we feel
bad telling you no here's some free
product well I did content for them
anyway with no payment no agreement
nothing the video performed so well that
they actually made me a part of their
program and have been
working with me ever since and have been
one of the most lucrative brand
Partnerships I've ever had so being
willing to work for free in certain
circumstances is worth it
um and not being afraid to ask I was
very timid to request Partnerships to
step out and be like hey you would you
mind wanting to work with me
um but to be bold to be clear to be
concise to add value
is
worth it I love it and and how did you
reach out did you go like yeah how was
it an email oh I totally slid into their
Instagram DMS that's how I have started
working with every single brand I have
ever worked with most of the time if
they're a larger company they will say
hey thank you so much for reaching out I
don't actually handle that that is this
person and they'll give you an email and
you go from there
that is amazing and I'm curious You know
Denise has some people helping is
anybody helping you are you just kind of
running all the stuff you're doing the
brand reach outs the video creation
I have a an agent that does help me and
they bring me certain brand deals but
most of the time I negotiate all of my
own brand deals
got it and are you doing your own
shooting your own editing all that kind
of stuff I sure am
I don't necessarily want people in the
bathroom with me while I'm washing my
hair for the internet
I love it I love it and uh that's those
are some powerful tips and if you have
the vision to want to work with the
company reaching out uh to them in the
DMS great tip you might look for the
marketing email one of the things we
sometimes look for too is trying to find
the chief marketing officer the head of
marketing on LinkedIn because that's
really where the professional decision
makers may be hanging out and just
different ways to put in the work and
hustle and one of the best ways to build
up a portfolio we talked about in one of
the previous challenge sessions right if
you're doing the RSP method you can be
building up a portfolio to position you
for brand deals which brings us to
number six which is private coaching and
so we're gonna go back to you Courtney
um you have some private coaching when
did you start this and break down kind
of what's Happening Here
this started back in late 2019 I had
been spending so much time answering
every single YouTube comment every
single Instagram DM every everything
that it was taking hours and hours of my
day and I saw that there was a need for
people to talk one-on-one about their
frustrations with their hair so I was
able to create some private online
coaching uh I used calendly that was a
perfect that is exactly what I needed it
managed my calendar it created these
Zoom meetings it emailed the person and
it collected payment
um I have since moved it behind my
paywall of my course so once you have
taken the course for me you then have
access to private coaching that came out
of a need of I was fully booked
completely
all day every day every available time
slot I had for private coaching was
taken up and I found that I was
answering the same 10 questions in every
single session that actually gave me the
content to produce a online course and
once that course was produced it
answered those 10 questions if you still
had questions after that then you can
book the private coaching sessions with
me
breaking it down a good sequence of
events because by doing kind of
one-on-one and leaving listening to the
comments that led to the formulation of
course uh of a course and coaching we'll
talk about online courses in a little
bit but uh Denise you had mentioned that
you haven't done this yet but you're
thinking about launching this what's
your plan
well I'm planning on launching a course
where I can do group group coaching
because I started out doing some private
coaching just to kind of practice to
kind of see what I wanted to do and I
discovered that I didn't like it because
it was just too time intensive so my
plan is to do where I can work with
groups of young women and address some
of the problems they have with
homemaking as a whole and we'll start
out maybe doing like a live session on
Zoom because I Really Work Well work
best with them live so I could have a
group of let's say 10 that I start with
live I found that on my weekly shows I
get a lot of similar questions about
homemaking or laundry or different
things like that and I'm starting to get
more and more email about different
things related to homemaking and I
decided that to do a coaching course is
going to be the best way to address that
and then I can also address their
specific question if we're doing
something like a zoom course something
like that
man that's brilliant and we have number
seven in just a second but I would love
for you to drop in the comments what
have you liked best or what has been an
aha moment from these first six tips or
maybe something around it maybe it's
reaching out in the DMS maybe it's doing
private coaching first so that you can
evolve that later I would love to hear
what you like best if you're in our
challenge group or if you're checking
this out on the think media podcast and
getting value of course smash like make
sure you're subscribed maybe share this
with somebody that is wanting to um you
know get started in the Creator economy
and if you're getting value and I
haven't joined the challenge group yet
to 1kchallenge.com there's still time to
get in if you like this kind of stuff
this is what we've been talking about
for seven sessions and we're on session
number six
um but number seven is online courses
and then stick around because we have
kind of a powerful question that I think
will give us a lot of um insights for
kind of a bonus number eight but online
courses we'll take it back to court knee
and you mentioned uh I think maybe a lot
I don't know if there's much more you're
hosting this on kartra private coaching
gave you the insight for the course but
what have you learned um in regards to
online courses
that if you're not promoting them people
who don't find them so continually
promoting the course is necessary and
updating your course because over time
you will learn more things you will go
back and you will see that course from
two years ago and realize that it needs
some updates so not being afraid to
update that course and promote it is
absolutely key and making sure that you
are creating the most powerful helpful
tool possible for your audience I think
there was a time when I would have tried
to make an online course and I didn't
know enough about the content in order
to make the course so it was actually
good that I did the online coaching and
answered these same questions over and
over and over to create in a really
valuable tool for
the people who needed it you know
Courtney that's interesting because that
is the Genesis I think of a lot of
online courses if they're done in the
right order that's actually the way that
VRA started first I I reached out this
must have been 20 uh beginning of 2016
and I actually offered to do free
one-on-ones with some people that I knew
pretty well and I said hey if I could
jump on with you
teach you this framework I'm thinking
about teach you like these these you
know what I believe will work for you
and if it works then would you consider
doing a video testimonial or giving me
some feedback and they're like yeah that
sounds great and so I was able to work
through some of the clarity of it
realize if they're like what what are
you saying and refine the ideas going
from zero to online course without
refining your ideas in the middle I
think doesn't end up with the best
online course or even something that
maybe values the individual the most so
there's a whole process to that and this
is what I think is cool is you could
just get started I mean I know that you
all might be overwhelmed there's a lot
to learn and and I think that what we
could be thinking of is geez like
YouTube and online courses and and
Affiliates and all this kind of stuff
well we're learning from some um
incredible creators that have been doing
this for years and so it's Brick by
Brick Rome wasn't built in a day
uh how do you eat an elephant one bite
at a time how do you build out your
channel and Affiliates and online
courses one step at a time depending on
the model for you and uh Denise you also
were uh mentioning have you launched an
online course yet or you're saying
that's in formulation right now that's
in formulation right now so my plan is
to do like a zoom course where I'm
working with these people live every
week and I've got the group there and I
can kind of perfect things I can answer
their questions I can see what their
needs are and then as we work through
that piece then I'll I can tweak things
to put my online course together so that
I can have a digital course that doesn't
require me being there live every week
but I want to start with the live every
week with a group of people because what
I found is that trying to work with one
person it just was too time intensive
for me
yeah really deep wisdom here and Denise
before my one final question for you I
am curious what has kind of been your
journey when you first discovered think
media and did you watch think media for
a while and when did you discover VRA
and how did that make a difference in
the growth of your YouTube channel
well I was probably watching a bunch of
different videos
because I didn't have a clue when I got
started and I came across one of your
videos and then after I watched a lot of
your free content and then you promoted
dra I joined that and that really made a
big difference because it really kind of
helped me cut to the chase it helped me
figure some things out and I was a
little resistant to learning if you'll
recall uh early on I wanted to do two
different things and when I finally
stopped trying to chase two channels and
just started focusing on my TNT
Community was when things really started
to grow the other thing that you always
talk about is being consistent and
I think that's important and um
sometimes I'm not as consistent as I
need to and then
um but that's my experience though with
VRA I found VRA through one of your
videos and it's made a big difference in
how I approach things how I think about
things I have a business because of you
and VRA I wasn't thinking about starting
a business I just wanted to have fun and
then I learned oh I can make a little
money here I can not only make money and
have fun but I can also serve people and
now I've got a community of people that
I'm serving because of VRA and like I
said I've got a business now because of
the things I learned in VRA
I'm so grateful to hear about the impact
and in just a second I'm excited because
I've got a powerful ending question that
I want to ask both of you uh but uh
Courtney I'm curious the same we were
reflecting I think we met back in 2020
when maybe we did an interview like this
or something but when did you discover
think media and just in video raking
Academy and how has that influenced your
journey
uh like Denise I found you when I was
trying to figure out how to YouTube how
to do the YouTubes your book YouTube
Secrets really impacted me and when I
saw that VRA was available I knew that I
needed to take advantage of that tool
and learn what I could from you because
you do know the ins and outs of how to
make the most out of this platform and
to have access to your wisdom and
knowledge was
critical was really helpful
I'm so grateful for you and uh final
question and then
um we'll hang out in the group just for
a second after we end the public stream
but I am curious Denise when you think
about uh this right here and uh
here we go yes when you think about okay
broke all of my technology when you
think about
this 58 600 subscribers on your YouTube
channel
how does that make you feel and when you
think about the work you've put in
when you were at zero and just kind of
the emotions that come with the growth
you've experienced and the impact
it makes me feel good and that I'm
making
so many comments from young women
and some young house men who say that
I've taught them some things that they
didn't get the opportunity to learn at
home for whatever reason so to know that
I am touching the lives of 58 000 young
Homemakers and everyone's a homemaker if
you're trying to create a space for
yourself or for a family
it just makes me feel really good and
that YouTube has allowed me to connect
with all of these young people and
seasoned Homemakers as well who need
what I have to share
and it allows me to share my voice
because one of the things that I learned
work in Community Health in nursing is
that sometimes it's not about the
message it's about the messenger and
sometimes you need the right Messenger
to get that person to hear what you're
trying to say and there are those people
out there that need to hear my voice and
I'm glad that YouTube has allowed me to
do that
and because of the things that I've
learned with VRA I'm able to share that
voice so
I'm just so inspiring it's inspiring to
hear about your vision for impact and
you really are making a difference and
you've come so far but you're also just
getting started I mean I'm sure you feel
the momentum you've got ideas and it's
just such an exciting industry to be in
and I'm curious for Courtney as well
Courtney when you look at this picture
of you with the silver play button and
all the work and time that you've put in
you're at 150 000 subscribers but every
content creator knows only a content
creator that's punched fear in the face
and punch perfection in the face and is
accidentally edited for three hours but
the project didn't save only that's like
you know not just about the accolades
but also about the challenges like just
what are some of the emotions that come
up when you think about what you've
built well I think that photo says a lot
because you can see my children's toys
in the background I am able
to
excuse me
so sorry
you're I'm able to serve my family from
home I'm able to
help it not only am I hoping my family I
am serving those 144
000 people that subscribe to me I get an
opportunity to hang out with them
and cough Mike gets up on a live stream
and try desperately not to
but
I am grateful that I get to
go into people's homes and brighten
their day and give them the courage they
need to in to try something new with
their hair while also getting to serve
my family from home
super inspiring and uh Hey live streams
are live streams I know that everyone's
sending you massive love because just
the boldness we just put ourselves out
there and have a great content and uh
this is a lifestyle and Courtney so much
respect for uh both of you friends share
some love with uh Denise and Courtney in
the chat and I would love to hear your
aha moment if you're uh especially if
you're over on the think media podcast
and as a reminder we are doing the tube
1K challenge if you want more content
like this make sure to get registered at
two and onekchallenge.com you can still
catch up on some of the past sessions
and then also uh thank God we got our
podcast Channel back we went through a
little snafu with a hack but hey it's
back and we have a brand new episode out
that if you haven't seen it yet click or
tap the screen right there so you can go
check out the latest episode of the
think media podcast